all right let's get back to the phones
last show before Thanksgiving we're
gonna hear from a bunch of different
people
um davidpackman.com Discord is the place
where you can contact me
um let's go right into it and see what's
on people's minds let's go to
is it borac or Baruch from Miami Florida
from Miami you're on the air please
unmute and you'll be able to talk to me
and last chance for borok from Miami
Florida last opportunity to unmute
yourself
and that's too bad let's go to Matt from
Northern California Matt you're on the
air next
hey check one two David can you hear me
you're coming in loud and clear Matt
David thanks man I appreciate you taking
the call so as stated I live in rural
Northern California we're about two
hours North of San Francisco and so is
that like Humboldt County pot area
uh just south um I'm part of the Emerald
Triangle Mendocino County actually
that'll be Mendo humble and Trinity
County got it um yeah you know it a
little bit uh so
from where I'm sitting it's just this
really interesting Nexus of rural sort
of urban resentment uh mixed in with
this infusion of kind of back to land uh
uh Berkeley liberal
um
organic uh
kind of culture clash and with that I
the certain the specific political
moment we're in I think is this
confusing identity crisis for especially
like rural satellite counties of the Bay
Area in Northern California there's
there's a lot of resentment towards
um San Francisco uh you know the the
rash of organized thefts recently the
these the the covid lockdowns
um but and also there's this kind of
libertarian uh common denominator in the
resentment that's
despite sort of some trappings of maybe
some trumpism they're generally pro-gay
marriage they're pro-cannabis
um but then sort of on the other
political side their Pro firearm
ownership so you know I guess I'm just
kind of curious about your perspective
David on what democratic messaging can
do to start letting these I I think
there's a huge uh place in the
Democratic party platform for a lot of
these ideas but there's some sort of
communication breakdown and disconnect
and I I'd love to know your thoughts on
messaging how have we given up on these
populations is there an approach that
you could see in inroad to get them
considering the blue ticket well I hate
to say this because it's such an
important issue but if you are you're
talking about strategy which is great I
love it uh if we want to talk about
strategy you probably don't want to
attack guns and gun owners I mean it's
it's it's crazy to say it but as we've
looked at in a number of studies when
the topic of Guns is a factor in
elections it tends to be good for
republicans and bad for Democrats and it
serves as a disincentive for people to
vote for Democrats so
I'm the ultimate pragmatist I'm not
saying gun safety doesn't matter I'm not
saying we don't have a massive gun
safety issue in the U.S we do
but
after the Sandy Hook shooting
with Barack Obama being president had
the House and Senate still weren't able
to get Universal background checks
passed even with like 88 or 90 percent
American support for it that doesn't
mean I'm saying we give up on the issue
at all maybe it means
you deal with it at the state level or
I'm not sure but for the group you're
talking about where gun ownership is an
issue don't
alienate people
by talking about guns and making it
central make economic issues Central
Etc and again I I know people will be
mad at me and they'll say David but the
gun issue matters I agree it matters but
I think it's bad strategy and it only
serves to mobilize Republicans and
others who might otherwise vote for
Democrats but don't want to because of
the perception that they're hostile to
guns so I think that's how I would start
making inroads with the group that
you're describing Matt
David can I ask a follow-up question yes
of course
uh regarding the specific issue of
cannabis and the Democratic party we've
found this really strange stalemate
that's emerged regarding the federal
legalization of cannabis and recently my
understanding is there's been some talk
on
um the Beltway of even Republicans
starting to come out in support of the
federal legalization yes and I guess I
have a concern that where
you know the Democrats could have put
that feather in their cap and the cans
gotten kicked long enough that you know
maybe maybe the Republicans will pick up
that can and put that feather in their
caps well there's two sides to that
there's two sides to that so you're
you're rightly pointing out hey you know
what Democrats could have done more on
federal marijuana maybe not legalization
but at least decriminalization before
Republicans start working on it and
saying we want that too the thing is I
don't know that without Republican help
Democrats would really have been able to
get it done so I actually actually I'm
not sure about that but I do think that
increasingly
um at minimum decriminalization is is
becoming more and more bipartisan which
is a great thing I don't care who's in
favor of it let's get it done
thank you David I appreciate your
thoughts my pleasure there's Matt from
Northern California
with a very powerful phone call coming
in
let's go
um oh I don't know let's try Mike from
Massachusetts Mike you're on the air
hey David can you hear me yes I can
I'm glad to be back
um called in last week we had a good
talk uh had a question regarding kind of
like the larger scheme like not so much
larger scheme larger scope of like the
future of the United States uh so we've
seen over the last you know 20 years
maybe a little bit more of that
there is a slow but steady General Trend
towards not just like diversification of
the population
um but also just like it's like a little
more
younger Generations as they come up to
be a voting age tend to be more liberal
more Progressive than yes previous
generations and overall they're slowly
gaining ground but what we've also seen
is that
as as that as that builds up the a
hostility and extremity of you know the
right wing and you know maybe some
people more willing to take action
against what they perceive to be
unethical or immoral people and policies
also seems to be strengthening as well
and I guess my question is do you see a
point where
like do you see a point where this small
but dangerous contingent of the right
reaches a point where they see like
they're ultimately going to lose the
culture War they're going to lose like
the like the overall where the country
swings in terms of politics and just
there where they ultimately they reach a
point where they just say we have to at
least in their minds we have to save the
country and actually take action like
they've been talking about for a while
when like do you think there's a point
coming of that I would go further I
think it's already started but for now
there aren't that many of them that are
just willing to willy-nilly go and be
violent yet I think a lot of them are
doing the violent rhetoric I think a lot
of them see themselves as at a certain
point we will have to go and become
violent in the real world some of them
have but yeah I think that that's it's
an absolutely legitimate concern and
when you look at long-term demographic
Trends
um things are changing and short of
killing people which I'm against and
think is disgusting there's a question
as to how are they going to be able to
resist it or push back against it and I
think they're going to become more
radicalized I think they're going to
become more insular a lot of this
rhetoric has gone totally mainstream I
mean remember the clips of Tucker
Carlson saying on Fox News immigrants
make the country dirtier and poorer and
stuff like that so yes I don't think
it's hyperbolic to be worried that
they're gonna go even crazier as these
changes continue to happen in the United
States and it's it's very scary
so a follow-up question if I may
um so we've seen a couple countries that
used to be like solid democracies and
now are only ostensibly democracies and
essentially our autocracies uh the two
prime examples in my mind right now are
and maybe there's more but the two prime
are Poland and Belarus
um now I don't know the entry I don't
know the careful details of their
constitutions we'll kind of checks and
balances they ever had in place and
whatnot obviously that those could cause
differences but I mean
do you see do you see something like
what's happened in Poland
theoretically possible here in the
United States well the degree to which
it's happened I think
Belarus maybe is a better example but
it's not
it's not a hypothetical in the sense
that the U.S for the first time a few
days ago we covered the story on Tuesday
was added to the list of uh backsliding
democracies for the first time ever
oh I missed that story that's this
concerning to know it's happening it's
happening now unfortunately and what we
mean by backsliding democracy is a slide
towards authoritarianism so it's not
sadly it's not a hypothetical it's
actually happening and the question is
how far will it go obviously I hope it
doesn't go as far as it's gone in
Belarus but uh that is that is happening
already and it's horrifying
uh one more and then I promise I'll let
you move on I know you got a lot of
people waiting um if that were to happen
do you see
do you see a possibility where the
United States as in like the 50 states
no longer exists down the road and I
don't mean like they've torn they've
torn themselves apart from War I mean if
something like what happens in Belarus
as you just said possibly happens here
and we continue down this backsliding
democracy path
um do you think that certain states that
like say New England in the northeast or
maybe the West Coast uh attempt to leave
um and get away from this backsliding
democracy or do you think that the
or do you think that whoever is trying
to take control in an authoritarian kind
of way
forces their hand to stay you know my
view on that is these are essentially
random guesses humans are so bad at
making that type of prediction which is
why why I say you know when Trump would
say at the State of the Union the U.S
will never be a socialist country never
is a really long time and historically
Nations fail
things that are completely inconceivable
take place I have absolutely no idea on
that and I'm not going to pretend to
really have an educated guess because I
think we just don't know anything's
possible
okay fair enough
um I appreciate your time I'm sure a lot
of people are waiting to call in so uh
I'm sure I'll be calling in again and
have a good Thanksgiving all right
thanks Mike likewise Mike from
Massachusetts with a number of important
questions